aquí tenemos la función f x igual a x +
2 al cuadrado más 1 para las x que son
mayores o iguales que menos 2 y queremos
determinar la función inversa encontrar
efe al menos 1 de x una cosa que te
puedes estar preguntando es por qué
estamos restringiendo el dominio de x
porque estamos pidiendo que x sea mayor
o igual que menos 2 bueno me gustaría
que pensaras acerca de eso me gustaría
que después reflexionar un poquito qué
problema traería que definiéramos la
función en todos los reales es decir
porque si la definimos en todos los
reales no vamos a poder encontrar una
función inversa pero bueno te lo dejo
para que los reflexiones y tal vez
después haga un vídeo explicando lo yo
va bueno entonces vamos a encontrar la
inversa de la función para eso como
vimos en vídeos anteriores lo primero
que se tiene que hacer es poner e igual
a fx lo voy a poner aquí
igual a x + 2 elevado al cuadrado
elevado al cuadrado más 1 esto lo que
nos dice es que a partir de una equis
podemos encontrar una y sin embargo
encontrar la función inversa es justo
encontrar algo que haga lo contrario
dada un h
queremos encontrar una equis de esta
forma en esta expresión lo que tenemos
que hacer es despejar x para encontrar
la función inversa vamos a hacer eso
déjame empezar restando uno de ambos
lados entonces nos queda que ye menos 1
es igual a x + 2 elevado al cuadrado
y ahora como debes estar esperando lo
que tenemos que hacer es sacar raíz
cuadrada
pero cuidado aquí tenemos que ser
cuidadosos con cuál raíz cuadrada vamos
a considerar puede ser la positiva o la
negativa como sabemos si queremos raíz
de menos 1 o menos raíz de menos 1 bueno
pues la restricción nos da una pista
como x es mayor o igual que menos 2
entonces x + 2 es mayor o igual que cero
simplemente sume dos de ambos lados
vale entonces esta expresión de aquí
adentro que voy a marcar en amarillo
siempre es positiva le voy a poner nada
más así positiva y por lo tanto al sacar
raíz cuadrada debemos tomar la raíz
positiva aquí hay que poner raíz de
menos 1 es igual a x + 2 es decir aquí
no le podemos poner el menos tiene que
ser la raíz positiva muy bien y aquí voy
a escribir algo que quizás debía haber
escrito desde el principio que es una
restricción para allí ya tenemos una
restricción para x ésta nos la dan desde
el inicio y de hecho debería ponerla
aquí x es mayor o igual que menos 2 y
debería ponerla aquí x es mayor o igual
que menos 2 pero también tenemos una
restricción para jeff si vemos aquí en
la gráfica que siempre es un número
mayor o igual que uno le voy a poner
aquí que ya es mayor o igual que 1 y eso
también se puede observar en esta
expresión x más 2 al cuadrado es un
número cuadrado entonces siempre es
mayor o igual que 0 de modo que yo
mayor o igual que 01 es decir que
siempre es mayor o igual que uno de
mayor o igual que uno ye mayor o igual
que uno y aquí también le pongo y mayor
o igual que uno ya me voy a olvidar de
la equis lo importante ahorita va a ser
la aie porque después cuando ya tengamos
una función en jeff esto nos va a dar
una restricción para su dominio muy bien
entonces déjame continuar con el álgebra
para despejar x aquí tenemos un +2 voy a
restar dos de ambos lados de modo que
nos queda que la raíz cuadrada de ye
menos 1 - 2 es igual a x para ye mayor o
igual que 1 mayor o igual que uno y aquí
simplemente voy a intercambiar esta
igualdad para que la variable
dependiente la x me quede a la izquierda
entonces me quedaría que x es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de menos uno menos dos y
otra vez para i
mayor o igual que uno muy bien entonces
empezamos con una expresión que a partir
de una equis nos permitía construir un
allí y aquí ya sabemos cómo a partir de
una y podemos construir una x es decir
encontramos una función que depende de
iu y está justo es la inversa entonces
voy a reescribir esto como que f inversa
evaluada en g es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de ge -1 menos 2 con la
restricción de mayor o igual que uno y
esto de aquí ya sería una respuesta
válida esta ya es una respuesta digamos
matemáticamente válida pero hay algunos
libros o algunos profesores que piden
expresar esto en términos de x y está
bien o sea da lo mismo si aquí le pongo
yo o zeta
oa sigue siendo la misma función
entonces nada más déjame reescribirlo en
términos de x para que esté en esta
forma que lo piden entonces quedaría efe
inversa de x
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x1 menos
dos con la restricción y aquí ya no es
verdad es x con la restricción x mayor o
igual que 1
ok entonces esta sería la respuesta aquí
tenemos la función inversa expresada en
términos de x y otra ventaja de tener la
expresada en términos de x es que es más
fácil graficar la simplemente pensamos
esto como el eje x esto como el eje y
hacemos todo como siempre lo hacemos
vamos a hacer eso vamos a ver cómo se ve
esta función
aquí en el plano entonces vamos a creo
que lo mejor es tomar algunos valores de
prueba qué sucede si le pongo x igual a
1 eso es lo menos que puede valer x
verdad porque es mayor o igual que 1 si
x es 1 aquí nos queda raíz de 0 - 2
entonces
efe inversa de 1 es igual a menos 2 efe
inversa de 1 es igual a menos 2 este
punto estaría en la gráfica de la
función que pasa si le pongo x igualados
me quedaría raíz de 2 menos 1 o sea raíz
de 1 es decir uno menos dos entonces
sería uno menos dos que es menos uno
entonces si x es igual a dos y es igual
a menos uno
efe inversa en dos es menos uno este
punto también estaría ahí si le pongo el
valor pues le voy a poner x igual a 5
para que aquí me quede un cuadrado
perfecto y le pueda sacar raíz entonces
sí x 5 tengo 5 menos uno que es 4 raíz
de 4 es 22 menos 20 entonces
5 me quedaría 0 muy bien entonces
tendríamos esos 3 puntos y me parece que
a partir de ahí ya podemos más o menos
dibujar la gráfica a ver si me queda
derechita quedaría algo como así siento
como así ok ok excelente y luego subiría
más o menos así entonces esa sería la
función de la gráfica y igual a efe
inversa de x de x
y en efecto coincide con lo que hemos
platicado desde el primer vídeo de que
esta gráfica es una reflexión con
respecto a la gráfica original tomando
la línea igual a x la línea de igual a x
quedaría más o menos así
quedaría más o menos así y como puedes
ver en efecto esta es una reflexión de
ésta con respecto a esta línea verde si
quieres hasta lo puedes verificar
tomando algún punto aquí el 5 tiene
altura 0 y aquí el 0 tiene altura 5 y
eso justo quiere decir que este punto es
reflejado de este